many movie stars don't have to pretend
to be badasses on the big screen because
they're already badasses in real life
from martial arts masters to decorated
war heroes
here are the most badass actors past and
present
from his unshaveable beard to his
unstoppable boot
the real chuck norris is even more
badass than the legendary one
born carlos reynores in 1940 in ryan
oklahoma norris began training in the
martial art forum of tongsudo and judo
while serving in the united states air
force
in south korea in the late 1960s norse
won the world middleweight karate
championship
six years in a row he even founded his
own style a korean-american hybrid
called chunkukdo
now known as the chuck norris system
among his other real-life feats is
training badass steve mcqueen in karate
i saw a movie call on any sunday i said
if
there's any one actor i'd like to meet
that's the man i'd like to meet
and so steve became one of my private
students chuck norris also had his own
line of action genes and was the first
westerner to earn the rank of 8th degree
black belt grand master
in taekwondo norris hasn't lost a fight
since 1968.
the father of western martial arts films
bruce lee gave us some epic fight scenes
but his big screen adventures weren't
the result of special effects
lee was the real deal and let's be
honest he probably would have kicked
brad pitt's ass in once upon a time in
hollywood
while bruce lee was born in san
francisco in 1940 he became a child
actor in hong kong
where he also began training in kung fu
lee returned to the u.s attending the
university of washington
and eventually opening a martial arts
school while lee is best remembered for
being a pioneering asian american movie
star
who brought kung fu movies to american
audiences he was also a
once-in-a-generation martial artist
both on screen and off bruce lee
developed his own style called jeet kune
do
or way of the intercepting fist famously
he could even knock a man down with one
and six inch punches bruce lee died in
his early 30s from cerebral edema
ronda rousey's filmography may not have
any oscar contenders but who needs to
collect awards when your nickname is
the arm collector as a child rousey fell
in love with judo
in 2004 she competed in her first
olympics in athens when she was just
17. rousey returned four years later to
beijing
winning the bronze medal she moved on to
mixed martial arts becoming the female
standard bearer for the ultimate
fighting championship
winning the women's bantamweight belt
and racking up a ufc record of six and 2
and 12 and 2 for her total mma career
a badass in the making rousey brought
mainstream attention
and millions of eyeballs to women's
fighting and she made herself a major
star in the process
in addition to her movie roles rousey is
also a professional wrestler with the
wwe
and she made history participating in
the first women's match
main event at wrestlemania 35.
born philip andre work junior in
schenectady new york mickey rourke is
not only a celebrated actor
he's also got a devastating right hook
rook was throwing punches
long before he was reciting lines
racking up an impressive 27-3 record
with 17 victories by knockout as an
amateur boxer in the 1960s and 1970s
the fighter returned to the ring after
establishing himself as a thespian
and then he returned again in 2014 at
age
62 fighting eliot seymour a 29 year old
former california state golden gloves
champion
roork knocked seymour down twice before
the referee stopped the fight
and awarded the win to work seymour
however claims he took a dive
whether or not the fight was fixed
there's no denying that rurk
an oscar-nominated actor for the
wrestler is badass on and off screen
dwayne the rock johnson is one of the
most popular movie stars in hollywood
before he was swinging from vines in the
jumanji series
revving 18 wheelers in the fast and the
furious movies or
flexing his massive biceps on instagram
the rock was doing all kinds of badass
stuff
for one thing johnson was a successful
pro wrestler
he was also a college athlete playing
defensive lineman for the national
championship winning miami hurricanes
unfortunately for the rock he played the
same position as arguably the greatest
defensive lineman ever warren sapp when
johnson asked sapp what he was doing in
the defensive lineman locker room
sap told johnson i'm here for your job
and that's exactly what he did warren
sapp became an nfl hall of famer
and dwayne johnson is well the rock
when this whole thing is over we're
gonna find a location and i'm going to
knock your teeth so
far down your throat you're going to
stick a toothbrush right up your ass to
brush them
arnold schwarzenegger practically
invented the modern action hero genre
that defined the 1980s
after all he was a one-man army in films
like the terminator predator total
recall the running man
and commando but you don't take down
thousands of bad guys without breaking a
sweat if you're not
a badass schwarzenegger built is larger
than life legend
one curl crunch squat and press at a
time
arnold eloise schwarzenegger was born in
austria in 1947 but he dreamed of coming
to america and saw bodybuilding as his
ticket
he racked up an incredible list of
accomplishments in bodybuilding
including seven mr olympias
schwarzenegger also served as governor
of california so
there's that for being the literal
definition of a self-made man
and one of the most accomplished
competitors in his sports history
schwarzenegger is definitely a badass
most movie stars would consider
themselves lucky to play one iconic big
screen hero
harrison ford has played two indiana
jones and han solo
ford's heroic roles are so memorable
that he placed twice in the top 15 on
afi's 100 greatest heroes list
with the rugged wisecracking
archaeologist ranking number two
i hate snake shark i hate him
throw in rick deckard from blade runner
dr richard campbell from the fugitive
and
jack ryan from the tom clancy series and
harrison ford has
plenty of unforgettable moments and
characters
that put him in the badass hall of fame
however
ford has proven the best way to be a big
screen hero is to be one in real life
a trained airplane and helicopter pilot
you ever have a flying dream
i have
[Music]
harrison ford has come to the rescue of
several people in danger
in 2000 he saved two hikers who got
stranded at the top of table mountain in
wyoming
the very next year he rescued a 13 year
old boy scout who got separated from his
troop
talk about a badass must be nice having
indiana jones come to your rescue
i told you
don't call me junior sir christopher lee
is known for playing some of cinema's
most
diabolical villains including dracula
saruman
and francisco scaramonga aka one of the
most iconic bond villains
while nobody was better at being bad in
movies
christopher lee was a good guy in real
life and he took on some of history's
worst
villains born in 1922 lee served the
finish in the winter war against the
soviet union in 1939
he joined the royal air force in 1940
and served in the long-range desert
group during world war ii where he
fought behind enemy lines and destroyed
german aircraft
lee kept quiet about his service well
into his later years saying
i was attached to the sas from time to
time but we are forbidden
former present or future to discuss any
specific operations
let's just say i was in special forces
and leave it at that
as if all this isn't badass enough lee
also set a guinness world record in 2007
for the most screen credits for a living
actor 244
film and tv movies on a long list full
of certifiable badasses
sir christopher lee may be king only a
badass can go from inmate to
action star a los angeles native danny
trejo became a criminal at an early age
getting tossed into juvie after
hitting a kid with a rock and he wasn't
a one-time offender
when you're on a cdc bus it's the only
bus on the freeway everybody
knows you're a criminal
he spent his teen years as the getaway
driver for his robber uncle
and he even stabbed a sailor with a
broken bottle when trejo was busted for
selling
heroin to an undercover agent though it
was actually just
sugar he was sent to prison he became a
celebrity in the slammer for his boxing
prowess
telling tmz sports i was lightweight and
welterweight champion of every
penitentiary i was in
and i was in all of them trejo did
stinson san quentin
folsom and soledad but his background
behind bars
isn't what makes him a badass it's his
redemption
the actor turned his life around earning
his high school diploma in prison
and serving as a drug counselor after
being released for
fighting and conquering his demons trejo
is a badass with merit
actor audie murphy is the most highly
decorated soldier in american military
history
murphy was born in texas in 1925 and he
helped raise his 11
brothers and sisters after his father
abandoned the family
dropping out of the fifth grade to earn
money as a sharecropper
following the bombing of pearl harbor on
december 7th 1941 audi murphy falsified
his age and joined the army at 17 years
old in 1942
murphy's most courageous act was
mounting an abandoned
burning tank destroyer and with a single
machine gun
taking on six german panzer tanks and
250 infantrymen
even more heroic audie murphy
single-handedly stopped the enemy
advance
which allowed him to lead his men in
driving the germans from holzwear in
he was that badass after the war's end
murphy was discovered by movie star
james cagney and began a successful film
career in westerns
murphy's high point as an actor was
playing himself into hell and back
though he wanted the story to reflect
the experience of all infantrymen
not just himself murphy said i've always
felt their stories should be told
i just play a part in it before he was
battling klingon zascotti the chief
engineer of the uss enterprise james
dewan was fighting nazis in europe
during world war ii
despite his famous scottish accent dune
was actually canadian
and when world war ii broke out he
joined the royal canadian artillery and
was shipped to england in 1940.
dewan went years without seeing conflict
training for an eventual invasion of
europe
when d-day finally arrived on june 6
1944 dewan was a key part of the
normandy invasion
single-handedly taking out two german
snipers without getting a single
scratch however deun didn't leave the
war unscathed he took four shots in the
legs and chest when a canadian soldier
mistook him for a german and opened fire
remarkably the chest bullet was stopped
by a cigarette case
but one bullet shot off dune's middle
finger on his right hand
following the war dewan had dreams of
pursuing a technical or
scientific career but when he heard
awful voice acting on the radio
he said he could do better and a star
trek icon was born
i may be captain by rank
but i never wanted to be anything else
but an
engineer mel brooks is behind some of
the funniest comedies of all time
blazing saddles young frankenstein the
producers spaceballs the list
goes on despite his reputation as one of
america's most
successful funnymen brooks's military
career is no laughing matter
born melvin kaminsky in 1926 in brooklyn
brooks was drafted into world war
ii while overseas the man of comedy
served as corporal in the 1104th
engineer combat battalion 78th infantry
division
his job title was combat engineer and
one of his duties was defusing landmines
yep we'd say he's a bonafide badass
brooks also fought in the battle of the
bulge
a german counter-offensive that was
halted by allied forces
effectively stopping the nazis in their
tracks despite seeing the horrors of the
nazis up close in world war ii
when brooks came home he figured the
best way to fight nazi tyranny was by
ridiculing them
brooks's the producers is perhaps best
known for the absurd musical number
springtime for hitler which makes a
mockery of his old wartime adversaries
don't let his folksy demeanor and all
around nice guy status fool you
jimmy stewart was a badass born in
pennsylvania in 1908
james stewart studied architecture at
princeton and launched a successful
acting career on broadway and in
hollywood
despite being one of the brightest young
stars of the day including his
nomination for an oscar in 1939 from mr
smith goes to washington
and winning an oscar in 1941 for the
philadelphia story
stewart was drafted into the army in
1941 and didn't
seek a deferment in fact when the army
said he was too skinny to serve
stewart gained weight to make sure he'd
qualify
jimmy stewart became a pilot in the army
air force ending his war service with
20 combat missions and rising to the
rank of colonel
he remained in the united states air
force reserve and was eventually
promoted to the rank of brigadier
general in 1959 his accolades include
two
distinguished flying crosses and the
presidential medal of freedom
so we are very proud to be here
and we're going to do our best to be
useful as soldiers
of the united states army stewart was
not only the nicest guy in hollywood
history
he was the highest ranking actor in
military history
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one